so sorry going back to the whole career
thing uh what happened after crunchyroll
i'm curious
um after is that where you started your
own youtube channel
actually i was kind of doing stuff on
sourcefed because
i felt like it was such a waste to not
be doing something on my own
and in my head i was like eventually if
i leave like i'll have something to fall
back on i think everyone at sourcefed
already have like their own main
channels
yeah yeah they did we were encouraged to
do it um to kind of like also
solidify your brand as a on-camera home
so they were helping you build up a like
a way to leave them um well i don't
think they realized it because we
actually had to sign over our channel in
the beginning
with your personal channels yeah we had
to sign it so they owns
just for like a normal paying job like a
wage did you get any like buyout for fee
for that or anything
oh nice dark i know but um
i wasn't i don't think i was a
monetizable partner channel
until until like six months into
sourcefed
and then i started caring that like they
were taking
i signed it off [ __ ]
my money um but also monetization was
different back in the day
there were no mid rules right like so
there was only like a pre-roll
and barely but also the money was way
more the out of the
city was way massive so i was not happy
but um but because
like you know i i can't do what i did
on super panic frenzy on my own i
wouldn't be able to hire septic like
that wouldn't be able to happen i didn't
have editors
so like i knew kind of what the
trade-off was and i was happy to be
doing so also the security
and being you know a hired host is much
better so
i didn't mind especially because i
wouldn't be able to start my channel i
think from nothing without sourcefed
very aware of that so you could i think
no
no one no one thinks they can right like
until you just make something like oh
[ __ ] people want to watch yeah
there's literally all three of them yeah
like i think that's like phenomenal i
would not i do not think i would have
been able to
i i don't know did any of you think i'm
gonna i'm gonna make something
i've started
i remember like when i uploaded my first
youtube video
well after one day he got five views and
i was [ __ ] people saw my bleach video
mom you only refreshed it twice right
that is literally the back in the day
where you had to be like you did account
your own refreshing
into the view count like you like it's a
hundred views but i've definitely killed
this at least
20 times and i showed this to 20 friends
and my mom five times that means there's
55 people out there who thought i was
listening isn't that such a wholesome
concern where you have to like
worry about your own views of how much
you refreshed them yeah and back when i
used to like all my own videos because i
was like
i need to up the likage man like it's
not enough dude i'll admit i still like
my own video
do you i don't know because it's like
dude i [ __ ] love this video i made it
of course i like this video [ __ ]
obama memes
damn joey that's a [ __ ] good video
who's that guy who's that guy he's just
got he's just got a champagne shelf just
for himself and every every video is
like
popping the champagne i'm the completely
opposite right because i don't like my
own videos but because
alan edits my videos right so sometimes
there's a joke where he has to
screenshot my own video and he always
likes it and sometimes i get comments
being like
oh why did giger likes his own [ __ ]
videos
i mean of course you do because you're
proud of the video you should be proud
of the video exactly
i feel like it's not my place to like
yeah i just like you
you're your own account you have the
ability to like i don't either i only
like ones
i'm sorry i've only liked ones where i
collab with people right like so like if
joey and i do a video i'll like
that for you so let's say you want to
join jerry look at all these likes
this is one more than normal oh my god
sorry you were saying about how you did
you do your own channel uh
oh yeah okay so i've been doing it and
then they gave it back to me because i
think they were afraid for me or of me
maybe when i left i mean rightly so
you know companies aren't normally known
for going back on contract
and kind of owning owning individuals
you know
that's kind of scary actually um we had
a new like executive head person that
undid all of that even before i left
because it was like that's [ __ ] up
like no these people like
they would be fine yeah so he undid that
and i left it was just
worked out perfectly the timing was good
um and then i left i did crunchyroll and
that was when my own personal channel
was doing quite well
probably because they wanted to hear me
talk [ __ ] about sourcefed
but also like i had like some nice
people watching and they were like
migrated over to my channel which was
really nice and
then you know i announced that i was
going to crunchyroll so they're like oh
like it's going to be even more
anime-centric or like we get to now
hear her talk to you about crunchyroll i
guess um
so well that's kind of scum why i left
crunchy
i mean i
dude i've seen those videos where it's
why i left this company and the videos
like yeah i was just kind of done
uh they're a nice company they're great
guys but yeah i was done and then it's
like a million views
yeah yeah yeah yeah you should have done
that i mean yeah i should have there was
a
country rule was a little bit of a a
different breakup
um it wasn't like aggressive or anything
like that it's just
um i still want it to work adjacent
around them and also
because they're so deeply embedded in
the japanese anime community
and i went to like every industry
mixer thing that happened in japan which
was really scary
still i mean back in the day was way
scarier but um
i they like knew me as a japanese person
and i did like voice acting too already
so i didn't want to damage anything and
i was afraid
that even if it wasn't anything negative
if i did kind of like a
why i left crunchyroll thing then maybe
companies would distrust me a little bit
you're openly talking about your
experience yeah and you know japanese
like totally frown upon that so i was
like let me not talk about that at all
ever again
yeah clean break but then i was doing a
lot of things with rooster teeth and uh
and then i'm just like i don't know i'm
asian like
i'm like brain
but yeah i feel like i cornered those
markets really yeah that's my advantage
um and yeah so i was doing a lot of
hosting and also like you know we had
the podcast the boys only club podcast
and stuff and that was really doing well
uh steve was doing really well with
sugarpine seven so i kind of was like oh
we could totally do this independently
like we don't need a company
ever again um but yeah and then i
moved to japan because i was like i'm so
sick of l.a
like i'm just too like truly sick of la
i yeah la is hard hello yeah la seems
very
intense it is now that i've been out of
it and maybe
i'm kind of like poisoned exposed facto
from like maybe
covid but i do miss la i miss visiting i
missed the hustle i mean it really is
neverland like i
genuinely feel like i did not age when i
was in la and
regardless of being there for eight
years it felt like i just got there
all the time and i don't know it was
like it is fun
if you can hit a sweet spot which i did
at one point but once you lose that
sweet spot in la
it's hard it's expensive things are
really stressful
yeah it definitely feels weird just
going to la and then just like kind of
dipping your toes in that industry just
for like two weeks then being like
okay
anything like industry related there i i
feel like man
i i feel like i've done a month's work
yeah it's showing networking and meeting
people
in the ex feels like a month jesus
christ yeah